the top seven guys not named izzy can
all wrestle not named izzy and sean
strickland all of them can grapple and
wrestle bring up all the guys bring up
all the guys from what yeah middleweight
right inside the middle no no no no wait
rankings middleweight please please pay
attention
i'm doing 3000 3000 things right now
yeah
um unfortunately pereira is going to be
he'll stay the champ and i think uh i i
admit that wrestling might be
a hole in his game but
you got a close distance and you're
assuming he doesn't
have a lot of wrestling experience after
two years with glover
hey b zero wrestling experience no he's
got training doesn't count he's got two
years that doesn't so marvin vittori
it's not going to happen for him no hold
on hold on b b marvin inventory can
wrestle
he can wrestle yeah he can rise and
wrestle but he gonna get
what
all that all that
happened what about this stand up about
derek
again all he's got to do
is be able to stand up against bronze
because so many guys can do that
there are guys that when you're that
tall
there it's a lot easier to do oh that
makes sense just the way he is
yeah had that much how much wrestling
honest
technique
has he had
all the rest he was a kick boxer for a
long one hold on but how long has he
been training mma i don't know how long
has he been training way long five years
five years oh dude no wait longer than
that waylon pierre so all he's done is
that anti-wrestling now izzy ain't
taking pierre down no but compared to
pierre izzy's [ __ ] chrome gracie on
the ground um i don't know about that
you know i i i think that at the end of
the day when you're that athletic that
tall that strong i think it's easier to
keep people from putting you on the
ground
and easier
so b so you're saying as long as you're
athletic and strong
you can get up
and stand up against the highest level
guys in the world well you because you
know that's not right well you know it's
not right right you know that's not
right because then uh pujanowski would
be undefeated right he could beat
everybody in the world he's the
strongest guy in the world strongest man
yes strongest guy ever yes i i'm gonna
say now tim kennedy could hold him down
well i could hold him down because
there's a thing that we call in the biz
technique right sure he goes a long way
well nobody he's not a stranger he's
glover to share is a hell of a wrestler
think about who's glover to share has
taken down and held down that has
nothing everybody could have nothing to
do with pierre but that's his heaven
hold on kevin holland went to ak to work
wrestle with khabib and dc
sure yeah it takes i i understand you're
working at a deficit there's not enough
hours in the day greg hardy greg hardy
sure way better athlete than pierre all
pro nfl sure all pro lived at att yes
you suck the att boys off right yeah he
lived there say i sucked them off he
lived there have you seen his jitsu and
grappling
now compared to pure athletically yeah
different [ __ ] planets uh well i
you're a little bit anybody who plays
football you think is the greatest
athlete no no no hold on no no no no no
no not the greatest athlete
ready
all pro i understand starter ready i
just saw you figure out starter sure for
the carolina panthers all pro sure first
team i don't know a hundred percent
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know so
it's not even like oh he played some
football right hold on i'm gonna repeat
it again yeah
started
for the dallas cowboys have you ever
heard of him yes oh yeah now pierre
still a hell of an athlete looks like a
hell of an athlete to me and has proved
everybody looks like at the top of his
game in in in glory okay it's a big deal
yep right name one guy he's fine glory
go
i've watched some of his fights name one
guy i know i don't know okay besides
sure name one guy he's beat in the ufc
besides sean strickland just give me one
well that's that's the big question yep
this is why you're casual i'm not casual
hold on b he's better better striker all
you gotta strike than everybody in that
way or no he's not gay or not nay really
nate who's better striker izzy as far as
mma goes he's a better striker uh we're
going to see about that we are we're
going to see about that because look at
the thing is he beats him yes you do 100
you want to bet on it yeah 5 dollars
okay
five five thousand dollars sure
guaranteed am i who's it where are we
even right now that's a lot of money or
even after the last campaign we're gonna
bet five thousand five thousand dollars
now hold on i love izzy i love izzy oh
no don't suck them off
this is what i love about the mma
community yeah
nobody besides the hardcores where tom
pierra until he beat sean strickland so
everybody's familiar that's not what i'm
talking about
no i'm just saying this is how this is
the this is the the wavelength
he's a terrible match for is he in terms
of striking that that we that that
that's what i would say terrible okay
have you watched her actually watch the
fight and he was getting the best of him
correct so he's actually getting the
best of him in his particular strength
which is standing and izzy was actually
actually is he had him wobbled in his
second fight
wobbled it was it it wasn't us it was
not at all not at all and then and then
he caught him with that shot and he
knocked him out anybody can get caught
like that so the smart money would be on
the champion on izzy people are saying
is he's doomed and stuff the smart
money's uneasy because is he's a
champion he'll find a way to win but
it's also the cool thing to say like oh
pierre knocked out straight it's
intriguing it's intriguing it's
intriguing i think it's very
short-sighted on the ufc i would vary
100 on that i agree 100 but we're going
to i would also bet
my entire year salary that derek brunson
beats them really awful matchup for him
awful because derek darrell closes
distance and puts him on on his back yes
that's all he does we're gonna have to
see because i think because pierre beats
darren till he beats uriah hall
and then after that there's nobody in
top 15 he gets by because of the
wrestling the rat they're going to wear
him out and then and then have we seen
him in the later rounds how's he do in
the third round with his stand up well
when his arms are tired his legs are
tired he's getting dragged to the ground
we're going to have to see all i know
and here's the thing
you have no idea i know what izzy does
when going gets tough i see him against
kelvin die he's ready i'm prepared to
die i'll bet on that guys no problem i
bet on that guy the new kid in town i'm
not bad no you always bet on israel out
of sight he's a champion for a reason
and he hasn't moved from that spot so in
my opinion people are confused because
they go ah he plays it safe you know
against your candidate yeah well all the
fans i hate that kind of talk that's the
dumbest [ __ ] in the world i'm going to
take this bet 5g i'm going to take this
bet and and shake it i will five
thousand dollars five g's i get easy
what i'm taking izzy yeah and i got
[ __ ] now i want to be very clear for
listeners brian is a fan of gavin newsom
and pierre yeah no that's what we've
covered today yeah dude you're a fan of
pierre i got my head on them
i'll let you uh pierre i'll let you
that's fine i get it yeah i get it yeah
it's fun you're gonna lose your fire
it's fine it's fine but newsom and it's
gonna and it's gonna bum you out and i'm
gonna be bombing news where i draw the
line right i understand but listen
because you read a book i understand
saying how hard to be governor now this
is this this is an exciting bet because
the smart money would be on israel out
of sonia i know that but here's what i
think okay
a strong hand
your hand's strong bubba now here's what
i say
um it's gonna it's an exciting bet
because
because
um is etk i believe you're gonna be very
surprised at pierre's wrestling his
ability to stuff take down and stan
everybody's gonna have a problem you're
not getting ready you're not gonna see
that you're not gonna see that
izzy's not gonna wrestle him
in the second or third round they're not
gonna bang really is he gonna sit on the
outside pick his shots wait for pierre
to come in and knock him out just like
you did whitaker you don't think people
see here's here's why i think pierrot
gets it done pierre hits harder
sure
and that's a big problem because his
technique is high level so he hits
[ __ ] hard and i think if if izzy
stands with pierra there's a chances he
picks him apart the promise pierre is a
very high level striker too and i think
that because he hits harder that's a
dangerous situation terrible matchup for
izzy or bad matchup or is he let's say
or let's say this and let's say this is
his biggest challenge right now right
now no but i'm saying a prime dude don't
get it twisted
prime hold on a prime whitaker is a
tougher matchup for izzy than pierre
we know exactly what pierre is going to
do we know a 280 what he's got there's
no mystery there right whitaker can
wrestle yeah he can kick he's explosive
he has the knees
wherever it's going to go
wherever you want to go he can do it
wasn't enough against izzy kelvin gassim
we don't know he's going to double leg
him he can grind him out has the cardio
for days we don't know what he's going
to do is he beat all those guys yes he
does is he versus kelvin gaslum finish
top three
middleweight fights or fights for that
matter of all time yeah is he is he is a
very special
mma community has such a short memory
when it comes to stuff you forget what
got izzy to the party b i'm not saying
you i'm saying the fan base in general
forget of course and everyone wants to
see the crown taken everyone see it i
don't i don't we bet 5 000.
i'm just excited i'm intrigued by this
i'm intrigued i want to see you got a
guy who's a high level
foot four six five who can uh who who
who is who hits so [ __ ] hard and
accurately right so so now i'm going oh
he hits harder than is he he's probably
got the same technique as is he right
different he has the same type
technique in
glory and kickbox yes now with his hands
down as relaxes against sean strickland
yeah again
fourth fifth round how's that go for you
yeah i'll tell you how that goes because
the defense isn't there is your if
you're now i don't think yes he's gonna
take him down i i he could yeah i i
don't know i don't know this first time
izzy has the advantage grappling which
is insane first time ever yeah i don't
know if he wants to mix it up is it but
then again it says he can't like go this
cop out because we can't stand with them
right that's why it's intriguing i just
think it's very short side of the ufc
we've never seen this happen in the
history of the uc that's to go okay
izzy's beat everyone what are we gonna
do this guy who can't beat it that
there's a reason why jump the line let's
see him there's a reason why he does it
there's a reason why they jumped the
line that's i would like to see him give
us one bad man get past that get us
excited
get his success i've never seen anybody
fast track why would they do that why
don't they build it up because it's a
risk because if he's going to lose to a
good grappler he's i promise you that
they want a high-level guy they want to
have fireworks her mansion mops the
floor with him so they want to have a
fireworks
do you need more meat like izzy's the
t-rex in jurass park where they toss the
goat in he's destroying everybody yes
they're like we need to mix something up
here dude so pure there's a ba there's a
story line there there's no rest for the
king but to me it's so short-sighted
let's say he and there's a chance let's
say he beats izzy what do we do now bad
well then you got a rematch right and
then you have to trilogy fight so what
about the rest of contenders they're
just chilling there because this guy was
an interesting storyline wow speaks no
english that's your champion the risk is
that you have the most colorful
marketable star in the ufc and if cara
starches him if he gets him because he
hits hard and he's really high and then
he hits him again that can ruin a career
but how long do you think about how long
do you protect pierre for this is the
next matchup darren till your eye hulk
because we know they won't wrestle yeah
how long do we protect them for
how long are we just gonna protect
pierre and for what because he's not
marketable no not at all yeah you
already have a problem with the russians
yeah that's gonna be that so you know
what i just feel like it's so
short-sighted yeah i also think if and i
do think this happens i think izzy beats
pierre there's nothing for him right and
if luke rocco destroys paulo casa
there's a narrative there because luke
former champ you could do that would
luke fight at 85 or is he going to fight
at uh 205.85 really yeah that's a [ __ ]
to suck down for him no no no no no no
yeah i thought he was fighting a 205 no
no but by the way this kid is just a
[ __ ]
scary looking rock